there is something around the fact that
good tick tock
content tends to be really really
personal
a little too personal at times um i'm
actually
something i'm really keen on is like the
lifelong digital footprint of gen z is
going to be the first to really have
that lifelong digital footprint i've
been
on social media platforms since i was
like nine
and
tick tock like no other platform makes
people compelled to share very personal
information probably because
mo you're you're consuming content
mostly from strangers so you assume that
the content you post will mostly be seen
by strangers so people and also just the
virality aspect of it the instant
gratification people will feel a little
too compelled to share
a lot which is probably going to bite
them in the butt later but cheers there
certainly needs to be a rule around uh
drawing a line
for in my opinion when someone's a minor
so there was a story around a woman
lexie hammond who had a job offer
rescinded because of something she
posted when she was 17.
uh and that struck me as completely
wrong it's like look like your brain's
not fully formed until you're in your
20s actually so by that standard maybe
we should raise that i think it's what
the 25 yeah yeah
but certainly when you're 17 it's like
you can say whatever you want when
you're 17 and in my mind like you should
not have to have that called out for the
world x years later uh that there i mean
that there are
to to me like a you're right like that
there's going to be a massive fear
uh for people who um try and step into
the public eye yeah i mean we're all
going to have to adapt because it's cut
it's kind of the same way that
celebrities or public figures have this
media trail that follows them now the
end of it every individual is also going
to have the same thing and the way that
yeah the media pinpoints
public figures and such for these things
it's
we're all going to have that type of
footprint
[Music]
today on ford my co-host is jules turpak
who has been an extraordinary voice for
young people on tech and digital culture
how it's transforming everything from
education work media consumption
she's someone who's been uplifting
independent political conversations
which is something i appreciate a great
deal she's super rational super fact
based and to me is a rising star voice
of the next generation pumped to have
her with us this week
[Music]
welcome back to forward and this time
we have an incredibly special co-host
jules turpak is here with us today
replacing zach zach is fired by zach
jules is the new zach
i'm mostly kidding uh but jules turpak
for those of you who don't know her
uh she's a major social media influencer
with hundreds of thousands of followers
on tick tock she's been creating really
informative incisive
pieces on the digital landscape and one
of the reasons she's here with us today
is that she was part of this fabled
white house briefing for social media
influencers
on uh the war in ukraine
yes i was and there was definitely a lot
of different media on this um i think it
felt a lot more sensational than people
who utilize the app would actually think
and also thank you for having me um but
i would definitely like to talk about
why the media ran with that story um i
think it's kind of died down a little
bit now but it was actually crazy to me
how long that was a story in the media
for like over a week i think it was
about eight days you know it's a big
story when snl decides to parody it as
they're
called open uh so why do you think this
did
take over the headlines for so long
i think
the biggest misconception is that
tick-tock is only a dancing app and it
definitely started as that it started as
musically and then formed into tik-tok
and musically of course was focused on
music lip-syncing dancing um but a lot
of people who are on the platform now
don't recognize what it is today it's
legitimately come a general media source
just like in the way that on the fox
news network or on nbc there is the news
segments but there's also the mass
singer and there's also america's got
talent where people are singing dancing
and eating fire
it's the same thing with tick tock there
is a wide array of media now so there
are freelance journalists on that the
platform there are journalists who have
worked for vetted legacy media sources
who now utilize the platform in a more
short form way and a lot of people
understand this if they're not on the
app and it's a way that it's the media
source that kids are clicking on first
when they're unlocking their phones
and it's where they're getting all their
information i think tick tock has it
surpassed um instagram and gen z users
it surpassed youtube and watch time in
terms
in terms of how much time is spent on
the app this is where people are getting
their information in world view i think
i believe it was fox news it was just
yeah jesse waters um
referred to tic tac is where like the
tide pod situation happened which is
like synonymous with gen z people like
oh they tide pods which was actually
like i feel like six or seven years ago
and it was on youtube around the time
when youtube was starting to be looked
at as also a general media source so
it's just like
all these kind of misconceptions about
the app right now and i think that's
what really did it so wait wait wait
you're saying that you're saying that
legacy media
um
just had their mind so blown by the fact
that the white house was doing a
tick-tock-centered briefing because they
have this out-of-date notion of what
tick-tock is that but there there's also
the the side of it that i understand so
i know russia had actually paid
influencers to like there was a scripted
messaging almost and that they were on
tock reciting this information so a lot
of people thought that this was a
similar scenario but it was not so we
weren't paid um we weren't pushed to
post after we came with like equipped
with questions that we did have to send
before and like they had to approve i
don't know if anyone's got denied but we
came with questions it was like any
traditional press briefing so they kind
of like prefaced with some um initial
remarks but then it was just questioned
and answered the entire time and that we
weren't supposed to record the whole
thing but someone did and the washington
post got a hold of the recording so the
whole recording is online too so it was
just interesting yeah a lot of the
coverage just kind of denied all of
those little aspects of it and just ran
with the headline of tick tock dance app
influencers all this different stuff
well this is something i'm sure we're
going to return to which is uh the media
narratives around this
but back to tiktok one of the stories i
will share is that uh i was talking to a
22 year old young woman
about
democracy reform and the forward party
and then she said have you talked to
tick-tock political influencers
and she said that's where she and her
friends get most of their news and
points of view for sure which is what
you're saying right now yeah and the
there was 30 of us there i would say
upwards of 10 to 15 of those that were
there yeah we're freelance journalists
who um one person i really like to call
out is aaron parnez he's hour by hour
reporting on the situation in ukraine
between ukraine and russia like
literally hour by hour super passionate
he has family that's from ukraine
everything and he's doing there's so
many of the freelance journalists that
were there who are doing the due
diligence and hard work of any other
journalist um so it's kind of
unfortunate that people boil it down to
the name of tiktok and the preconceived
notions of that um there were definitely
some creators there that were
more lifestyle-like which definitely
confuses people a lot of the media was
running with maybe dance videos from
different people um but what to know
about tik tok and just how
kids and not even kids just like younger
adults who are consuming media today is
like they want to follow people who also
they maybe aspire or relate to their
lifestyle as a whole so yes i don't
think uh maybe a dance video here and
there really knocks someone out as um
not credible in their
other type of content it's just a piece
of their content and people just like to
follow these people who yeah they have
like share their holistic life and they
can aspire to so it definitely
i can understand why people were like
well why are these lifestyle creators
there maybe but um that's basically why
people are drawn to them yeah there are
people who can post different types of
content
and it doesn't necessarily diminish
their capacity to
add value especially if they have a huge
audience because the fact is and this is
where tick-tock actually is ideal
certainly people want to be able to
consume
uh entertainment in different ways and i
now know some young people who just
turn on tick tock as the first app uh
and then they'll get entertainment but
they'll also get some uh information uh
and and sometimes it can be from the
same person so i i'm going to share my
experience with tik tok which by the way
if you're listening to this i am on tick
tock
follow plug
plug well so i i started out on tick
tock during the
presidential
where my team said hey
uh think that you actually could perform
well on this
um so let's give it a try and then we
did a few videos that did really well
um so i also have you know a few hundred
thousand followers on tick tock which
um there was a period when i might have
been one of the sole political figures
now i've been joined by a bunch of
others yeah there is something around
the fact that good tick tock
uh content tends to be really really
personal like it like you're going to
feel like you know someone because
you're going to see them
talking dancing like it kind of has to
be intimate a little too personal at
times um i'm actually
something i'm really keen on is like the
lifelong digital footprint of gen z is
going to be the first to really have
that lifelong digital footprint i've
been
on social media platforms since i was
like nine
and
tick tock like no other platform makes
people compelled to share very personal
information probably because
mo you're you're consuming content
mostly from strangers so you assume that
the content you post will mostly be seen
by strangers so people and also just the
virality aspect of it the instant
gratification people will feel a little
too compelled to share
a lot which is probably gonna bite them
in the butt later but
there certainly needs to be a rule
around uh
drawing a line
for in my opinion when someone's a minor
um so there was a story around a woman
lexie hammond who had a job offer
rescinded because of something she
posted when she was 17.
uh and that struck me as completely
wrong it's like look like your brain's
not fully formed until you're in your
20s actually so by that standard maybe
we should raise that i think it's the 25
yeah yeah but certainly when you're 17
it's like you can say whatever you want
when you're 17 and in my mind like you
should not have to have that called out
for the world
x years later uh that there's i mean
that there are
to to me like uh you're right like that
there's going to be a massive fear
uh for people who um try and step into
the public eye yeah i mean we're all
going to have to adapt because it's k
it's kind of the same way that
celebrities or you know public figures
have this media trail that follows them
now the end of it every individual is
also going to have the same thing and
the way that yeah the media pinpoints
um public figures and such for these
things it's
we're all going to have that type of
footprint
which is crazy to think about and look
like i i'm not like a tick-tock hype
person like i have a lot of
um my disdain towards tick-tock there
it's done great things for me it's why
i'm sitting here now like i've gotten
great reach and
without tick-tock no other platform
would have given me a lot of the
opportunities that i've been able to
receive but also um i openly critique
the platform coincidentally on the
platform a lot of the times um i've had
friends that do so and they've literally
had their accounts banned that's not
cool which is crazy so like i totally
understand also yeah the distain towards
tick tock um
and obviously it's owned by by dance
which is in china everything um so there
were those critiques that i'm like okay
i understand but there's definitely more
nuance into what goes on on the platform
yeah
[Music]
so do you think that the white house
tick tock influencer briefing was one a
good idea
and too well executed
i think so i 100 think it was a good
idea in theory i did think it was weird
so a lot of the people came from gen z
for change which is an organization of
like uh like 500 creators i believe i
didn't i wasn't invited through that i
was invited through an individual who
just like helps with youth insights
within the white house um
i they didn't seem to really yeah maybe
vet the individuals there yes they could
like trusted like oh they're in the
reporting realm or
they have an audience that really trusts
them it did feel a little too
casual i would say like it was very
question and answer but even like uh jen
saki at points was like uh i feel like
comfortable like i can nerd out here
like a little too [ __ ] like
just casual friend like and obviously
we're there for a very serious reason
and that's what the focus should have
been in the media i totally understand
the initial coverage and the initial
like restraint towards what was going on
but the big focus there was
the uh ukraine and russia situation
which
should have been more covered in the
media and the information they provided
us was actually very very strong so and
something that we can talk about here
today too yeah so what did they share
with you that would be news 2 folks
and it's tough for people i think
because you wake up and the first thing
you do is you you look up what's
happening in ukraine
and every social media platform is a
very very deep well you could spend
essentially your entire day uh digging
in
now so what did they present to you all
and and uh did they have information
that might not have been uh in the
general public yeah so all the
information
from my understanding listening to
briefings and stuff had been
said yeah it's out there somewhere
within the media or within their press
briefings but they kind of not that they
intentionally pushed three main points
but the three main points that i got out
of it were of course that they want to
de-escalate the situation as soon as
possible the second was that during the
this was now a week ago a week and a
half ago so before
when this press brief when this briefing
was happening the week before that sent
over 250 million dollars in aid
humanitarian
military um
and
that was obvious a big feat for them to
do that so quick which they were really
pushing i think now just like five days
ago they approved another 800 million in
aid for military but also the other the
third and kind of the most prominent
point to me was why russia is having a
tougher time with this and it kind of
boiled down to ukraine being more
equipped than they
initially had thought russia having like
logistic and mechanical issues and also
um low morale amongst the soldiers and i
actually saw that you had quote tweeted
a thread about this and i think that
specifically low soldier morale was very
very interesting to me on the call
and it's really continuing to affect
russia
yeah i i we can dig into this because
the the thread you spoke of struck me as
fascinating and you imagine
an army like the russian army would
consist of
uh people who would be
ultra loyal
and professional
but it turns out that a lot of them are
conscripts a lot of them are from
poor small towns
and ethnic minorities
the twitter thread you described which
was from a russia scholar went through
for example a list of wounded
soldiers that had been publicly made
available and over half of the names
were from ethnic minorities
and apparently russia is an environment
where if you do have resources like
let's say a college graduate you can
avoid getting drafted
and so the the folks who are
being uh sent out there are often people
who are less educated less access to
resources
uh and uh it's not something that that
is
necessarily being
uh prized or sought after by folks who
have the ability to make a choice yeah
and how the white house framed it during
the briefing i believe also so in the
thread um was kind of important that
these soldiers
didn't even they still don't initially
know like what they are doing there like
what their sole purpose is and many
didn't even know until the night before
that they were going to be invading um
so there's that aspect of it so
imagine that yeah imagine what are you
doing
like you're going to the border and then
all of a sudden you're crossing the
border and then you're standing with you
know with your weapons in front of
ukrainians who are fighting for their
lives and you're like god like i wasn't
even told that we were doing this yeah
because a huge part of like your
willingness to fight is obviously like
your patriotism towards your country and
everything and there's a lack of
transparency there
and yeah so there was that aspect of it
and um
it's just insane like these guys are so
young and
and to think of like where we're at with
culture with tech and everything to be
honest like not that a physical war
feels outdated it doesn't in a lot of
means but when it comes to a country
like that that is
depopulating um and just literally
sacrificing those who are in yeah poor
positions
it's an insane situation to think about
and it's
extremely unfortunate for all parties
involved right now yeah that's another
part of the analysis which is that
russia is aging yeah it's depopulating
and so they don't have a surplus of
young men and the young men that are
available are being conscripted
into service they're getting paid in
some cases
poverty wages
and so this russia observer
advised trying to
let them know that if they defected that
they'd get a certain amount of money and
that they'd have a pass out um he
estimated that you might be able to get
maybe 50 000 soldiers to defect which
which would be an enormous uh amount
relative to the size of the russian
force and then even those who didn't
leave would be extraordinarily
demoralized by watching their
compatriots just disappear
so i thought this was a fascinating
argument and it felt true yeah it felt
like okay if you are
like a 20-year-old kid from some
town in siberia who gets conscripted and
then you show up and all of a sudden
you're you know facing people who are
defending their homeland like if you
have the ability to
maybe
extricate yourself from that situation
it might be something you would very
seriously consider and and that would be
an enormous win for everybody yeah i
mean we see in the us too obviously
people are flocking to urban areas and
that's also what they were saying is
happening in russia because you know
back a few decades ago it was mostly
yeah the rural families had a ton of
kids and then it was the rise of like
birth control and all these different
things which have just added up and also
is um
has to do part with that depopulation
situation
and
i i mean i don't know if you had seen
this because it was kind it was not
super covered in the media but there was
the zelensky um
deep fake that was really poor quality i
don't did you have did you see that i
just knew that it was a deep fake it was
debunked oh yeah it was like super poor
quality it did get in there like news
articles and like there was on a
prominent um ukrainian news website it
quickly got debunked but it also just it
shows where also we're heading with
warfare and there was um two different
situations in regard to wiperware which
is a very strong type of malware that
with a few files can just completely
shut down um
the software it was found a few months
ago the u.s had found it obviously
because the u.s has been um
like
this has been piping up for the past
year um so the u.s had found it uh wiper
rare in a railway system in ukraine
which ended up being used for over 1
million of the refugees to get out of
ukraine and also um
microsoft had found this
trying to
target the ukrainian financial system
which is insane because they were able
to end up blocking the code within
a few hours but just a few years ago
probably three to five years ago they
were saying that would have taken them
weeks if not months
so the fact they were able to detect
this stuff so early like thank god but
it just shows because of yeah these
depopulating depopulation situations
what we're gonna have to be up against
not because
maybe people would prefer these cyber
attacks but like that's also what
countries are gonna have to resort to
well it's it's clearly the future of
warfare uh and
this particular war is playing out on
social media with uh one side investing
have only the other side not yeah so
if you were to log on to social media
you would think that ukraine is
absolutely crushing russia because the
ukrainians are posting all these videos
about
successful attacks on various tanks and
russians giving up their weapons and
being taken captive and a bunch of other
things whereas the russian side is not
meaningfully investing in uh in this
form of propaganda because on their side
uh there's just much less reward
um
but
there there is going to be
i think an ongoing
uh digital
front to all of these
wars
uh moving forward
well also it's like
growing up and i i still feel this way
and i feel like younger generations feel
this way big text power is more
prominent than that of the governments
throughout our lifetime like in terms of
influence in our day-to-day lives yeah
like what's in our face at all times so
right now
this microsoft situation was interesting
because
what we see a lot in the media is a very
versus situation between big tech and
the government
but it really needs to be cohesive and
we got because we see the top tech
talent goes to big tech that doesn't go
to the government which you've actually
talked about often
it's just going to be like how do you
even see
the relationship between big tech and
the government playing out moving
forward even the ccp is scared of their
technology companies in terms of power
well at this point facebook
has billions of users it's more vast in
its reach than any nation state uh and i
think this russian
troop morale situation actually is
really important on
this point yeah so hear me out let's say
you're a nation state you have a
standing military and
uh unfortunately you're in a time when
like
institutions are faltering and like
loyalty towards let's say the the the
state is not what it was yeah and so you
still can script people you know in some
cases you know like frankly they're not
that um excited or even willing but you
can script them and then you you send
them out and so then uh
in the old days i think it might have
been ridiculous to say hey like let's
just try and get them
um to defect let's all like offer them
material comforts for them to come over
because like in most wars soldiers would
not have
been open to that because they were
fighting for something that they
believed in
um and or there was like a very strong
chain of command or a whole other things
but like now in 2022 you actually sense
it's like oh that could work yeah you
know like the loyalty on the ground
could be completely absent uh and and so
if you give them a a choice they might
take it so there's like this this
fascinating dynamic where
uh you have
in my opinion
like uh
putin who's trying to adopt like uh an
old school
war
yeah um and the war is awful and immoral
and like it it's heartbreaking to
imagine all the people that are
suffering and the 10 million ukrainians
who've already fled the country and
everything else
um but then if you were to try and
counter it like you shouldn't take for
granted that like that that there's
troop cohesion in the rest of it you
actually should imagine like wait a
minute like that there like that this
might be
um
uh crumbling in ways that aren't clearly
evident and we can capitalize on it
there was another uh editorial that made
a similar case which is that the u.s
should be accepting
defectors from russia and mass
because there are a lot of russian
professionals
who
want nothing to do with this war
and then if they were given a choice to
immigrate to the u.s
that's a real blow to
russia russia's economy russia's society
and it could also increase the pressure
um on putin and when i read this i
thought to myself
as an american i would gladly accept
russian refugees if i thought that it
would hasten the end of this conflict um
certainly i think most americans would
gladly accept ukrainian refugees i think
that's kind of a no-brainer but then you
think russia and this goes back to the
entire
uh corrosion of these uh
uh you know like notions of
uh of national identity which is like
you know do you think the average
russian citizen is excited about this
war i mean i'm sure some have bought all
of putin's propaganda hook line and
sankara super into it but a lot of
others would want nothing to do with it
and even if you they don't have strong
feelings against the war if they were
offered uh the chance to
uh defect the united states some might
take it purely um because they thought
they'd have better opportunities here
so
i don't know how you feel about that
suggestion but when i read it i thought
like that this makes sense and
apparently the u.s had adopted similar
attacks at earlier points in history
where they were accepting
accepting defectors and refugees well i
also think
we we kind of moved past it but your
point to that thread about um the low
morale and soldiers you had a really
good proposition in regards to that you
were saying to provide them with like
20k in order which is apparently more
than a year salary for that yeah which
is crazy so
talk to that too i found that super
interesting oh yeah so this was not my
proposals this uh this proposal someone
pitched me gotcha it was a government so
as a us government official and the us
government official pitched me because
he wanted me to try and uh popularize it
on twitter yeah for sure because that's
one of the things i'm good for in the
world
well so if there was you a random us
government official they're like well i
can't put it out there but like let's
try and get someone excited about this
so the proposal was twenty thousand
dollars per soldier fifty thousand
takers it's a billion dollars uh and
given the billions and billions that are
going to be spent and the tragedies
and the loss of life like everyone here
would be like shoot i'd put out a
billion dollars to get 50 000 defectors
like that for sure heck even like
they're probably human beings who would
put out a billion dollars you know if
you you were to get like uh you know
like a musk or a bezos or someone and be
like hey you want to put a billion
dollars to speed up the end of this war
they'd be like sure
because they would do it for
humanitarian reasons but also probably
because everyone would love them um and
so my mind actually went to how the heck
you'd execute on this it's like if you
even had the billion dollar
uh
fund set up it's like well you know how
do you communicate to the russian
soldiers that this is a possibility how
do they trust it like where do they go
um you know it it wouldn't be
plausible for them to just somehow like
you know arrive in the us they'd
probably wind up in
um uh in poland or one of these
countries that yeah that's more adjacent
so
so those are some of the things but you
should know like a legitimate government
official reached out to me and said like
hey this is like something that we
should be exploring it could be
something just he felt yeah um but i
thought that it was an idea that really
should be out there more because if
there's any chance of it working it
would be funds and time well spent yeah
because a huge part also why people are
motivated to fight for their country is
money in itself obviously they're not
being commentated much if the their
opponent is providing that for them and
mixed with the little morale
seems like
an easy situation there to move forward
yeah so you know like i mean hopefully
this conflict gets resolved as quickly
as it can but if it's continuing on and
anyone listening to this is like you
know that's not a pretty good idea you
know maybe we should all invest some
time and energy on it trying to get this
defector encouragement fund
[Music]
i think this all kind of ties into when
we're talking about um big tech moving
forward and the role that they play in
this um i think it's pretty
straightforward when it comes to the
software interferences and like malware
and everything like that
how to approach those
what gets sticky of course and is a huge
maybe maybe their buzzwords right now
but a continuously growing conversation
among social medias the misinformation
and disinformation situations
meta of course had to uh
step in with a lot of like hacking
situations over the past few weeks which
that's again something that's pretty
straightforward in how to approach
but when it comes to messaging we of
course saw last week the news about
hunter biden dropped and so basically
new york times confirmed that the laptop
was real which i think everyone
kind of felt that way it was never
confirmed or denied by the biden
administration before like a political
article came out about 50 intelligence
experts saying that this was russian
disinformation so obviously we're in the
war
with ukraine and russia right now and as
the conversation about misinformation
and this information grows
and there's a lot of distrust in how the
media has covered russian disinformation
in the past
how are you viewing that situation as
well
yeah i'm of the mind that uh you know
unfortunately everything is going to be
partisan attacks yeah you know like in
my mind's eye
i
never was that attentive to what the
heck hunter biden might have done
because
he's an adult and like last i checked
you know like if you have an adult child
who's doing something it's like you know
it's like
um as long as
you know you're not directly there like
helping them benefit or something along
those lines
could someone like hunter biden maybe
traffic on like an implicit connection
like of course
there are i'm sure legions of political
uh progeny
out there
trading on uh on their connections that
way including of course like the trump
kids and the rest of it of course um
much more directly so i i was always
like this is like you know something
that um certain people are going to to
be up in arms about others like are
going to look at it
did i ever think it was true or untrue
like i i assumed it was probably true
honestly
or at least there was something to it
but i didn't like care as much because i
didn't think it would affect
um you know like policies necessarily it
does speak to the media environment
wherein though where
at this point anything that's bad for
your team
uh you you will attack as uh you know
made up misinformation partisan attack
and it's degrading trust for everybody
because
no you don't know whether someone's
ignoring a story because it doesn't have
merit or because it's bad for
uh for their team
yeah 100 i think i'm with you on i never
really paid much mind to the hunter
biden situation i remember like
what the 2008 election i was maybe
middle school or something like that
when they were
really pinning like sarah palin on maybe
like it was like her daughter was like
pregnant at a young age i'm like i
understand to talk about the family unit
but to an extent
there's it's a an individual they have
autonomy and everything
i definitely think with the hundred
buying situation it's def more ingrained
in of course like foreign affairs in a
way and just like um obviously his
different positions and his jobs and how
joe biden like uplifted him in those but
i i yeah i doubt we're going to see
anything come out of this and the big
story to me is just how yeah the media
portrayed it and
i'm just interested to hear too like why
do you think now
the new york times came out about it why
did they feel like now was a good time i
know they covered it in 2021 even though
kind of the news broke about all this in
2020 and they were saying like nothing
concrete they they they didn't know what
was true and what was fake and kind of
like how we're talking right now
and then um the other day after that
article broke they also there was like
an opinion piece um regarding it's never
a good time for the hunter biden story
so why do you feel like
they felt like this was the time to do
so if there's probably not going to be
anything coming from it
no i i'd imagine because uh there was
just so much mounting evidence that
they looked at it and were like well
this is going to be out there so
i might as well yeah uh
step forward and verify that yeah yes we
too think that this uh israel and
happened
uh
and it could also be that there's not an
election on and so that they their
team's not uh in jeopardy at a given
moment
because
you know joe's not going to be on the
ballot until 24 if he does run again
yeah
and
to me too it was just because i remember
twitter completely suppressed the story
and also the new york post account when
they came out with the story back in
2019 2020 the account was like just
couldn't post for two weeks too
which
just that interference in big tech like
completely controlling the narrative of
that conversation
and again i don't think anything's
coming from this and i don't think it's
a huge story but it just goes and a
reminder especially for the younger
generation who's kind of like first
seeing that firsthand that that story
had a huge relevance it was came up in
the presidential debates and was quickly
shut shut down when trump mentioned it
they moved on um i think it's all just
kind of adds up and feels like legacy
media kind of digs themselves
in
for short-term games and like a
long-term hole that they're digging
ourselves in and that's you know we're
seeing journalism move more towards
independence and obviously the younger
generation flocks to independence for
their media um it's one reason why i
think you're so important jules and the
people like you is that i think people
instinctively when they watch you
uh comment something or create something
it's like i don't think jules is uh you
know in anyone's pocket
because definitely not
[Laughter]
definitely not because she's just uh
putting her own stuff out there i think
it's one reason why i had a joke too
when i was running for president where
it's like you realize that i'm not part
of the machine because there's no way
they would send the anonymous asian guy
who wants to give everyone money like
that that's not like that their
appendage
um uh and that there are uh
unfortunately at this point are like you
know
tens of millions of americans who have
started to tune out various media
sources because
they feel like the the the media has
been in the tank for
one thing or another i mean i went
through a version of this so check it
out i run for president
um you know some people uh get behind me
and i'm super grateful and excited about
it um and then cnn starts having me on
um and spelling your name or when do i
know what's up then no so
i was saying like i like that cnn
actually calls me up and says like hey
do you want to comment yeah uh on the
race and at first i thought this would
be like a two-week thing i'd be like
sure like i'll show up for a week or two
and try and jam some points in there
that i'm into and then when i showed up
on cnn there were a bunch of people who
supported me who were like oh like you
know yang sold out yang has become a
corporate chill etc
and then part of me was like interesting
and then other people were like oh you
know you know like yang will like um
make use of this in a positive way uh
and it struck me how so many people just
completely
hated or mistrusted anything they
thought of as like corporate or
establishment media
and
you know i also see why that is
um you know like i
had a positive experience
commentating on cnn for the most part
um but there there were people who
uh really
started to
uh you know attacked me over like my
agreeing to be on cnn yeah um
and there was part of me too that's like
well shoot like uh you know how are we
gonna fix this because
people now
uh are separating these ideological
camps and you have uh you know like a
very fairly limited
um news universe yes and this is one of
the things i encountered when i was
running for president where i was like
why are we doing this like and it turns
out there are a limited number of games
in town you have the three major cable
news networks
you have
uh pbs and npr
and then
like the
major news networks
or so the major broadcast networks news
operations but they're very limited like
if abc news has you on you're not going
to go back on abc news for like three
months you know what i mean
[Laughter]
and so
uh so then after that then you wind up
in the independent media layer and then
that layer is much more varied and
robust it can include any podcaster that
has a significant following i will also
attribute the independent media layer to
like obviously 98 of my success of your
yeah 100
yeah it's one reason why i feel
indebted to so many figures in that
landscape and i have a natural affinity
for and excitement around
in independent media
[Music]
so there are these
folks that are
trying to to make a case
um in different ways and they commingle
different forms of content um
but there still is this strange like
sort of institutional layer
um and it's not based on audience uh at
all i mean like the biggest influencers
have
audiences that are you know five ten
times as large as the average cable news
broadcast
and yet the cable news
uh network still control like this news
narrative
in a way that
um i think
is
you know like you can see it weakening
somewhat but then
you're not sure
uh when the dynamic shifts
so this is something that you know i'm
um investing time and energy and trying
to figure out uh what the alternative
can be uh you know what are the
ingredients that make it so that there's
like a certain level of credibility for
like a cnn news segment that does not
hew to
you know you name your like let's say
breaking points for sure and um the nelk
boys had had trump on for an interview i
didn't get to watch it before it was
taken down off of youtube but a big
critique of that i remember um jimmy
kimmel late night host um was like uh
these small youtubers yada yadda
interview donald trump and it's like
their youtube videos get more views than
your late night show which is just crazy
for him to boil down to small youtubers
i don't think yeah i don't think they're
credible i was able to watch like their
candace owens interview for example and
the questions were very you know surface
level lacking and like
being tough on her and i assume that
might have been the same for trump but i
didn't get to watch it but yeah the
these huge
media networks like we saw with how they
covered the tick tock white house
situation they're
really trying almost to like uh
be in denial of maybe how it's evolving
and like where yeah the power is oh yeah
there's this really interesting dynamic
where you have like the legacy media
layer uh hanging on and then you have
this wave of wave of independent content
creators
and there is like a real kind of war on
and the independent content creators are
winning in terms of audience and reach
they
haven't gotten there in terms of
uh institutional credibility uh and
uh money yes um because most of the
money is still hovering in this
institutional layer
yeah like if we can solve for this
uh then there'd be like a
you know a major shift i think in the
both the media and the political dynamic
it's
a real
problem i i'd say it's like a you know
multi-billion dollar problem because
that's like this yeah this is the size
of it i have been looking at things that
can be done
it's been good fun
um but it's a project that requires
significant investment energy
yeah because regardless of whether it's
legacy media or independent media
no one
neither is like completely wrong or
completely right within independent
media there's still
you still have to play into an algorithm
in order to reach your audience and like
there's there does um there is often
strong community but you're also very
much at women's with algorithm also
sustaining yourself with sponsorships
everything like that those little things
still come in in regards to outside
people
outside people infiltrating but
with legacy media there's of course the
checks and balances which are super
important independent you have less
resources within legacy media
traditional media you have a ton of
money behind you which is good and bad
for a lot of differing reasons
independent media there's more autonomy
but um
yeah your stability long term is harder
there and it's harder to get like really
strong people to be able to be stable
for the long term oh yeah it's tough
well so one of the stories that really
stuck with me
um was crystal ball when she was in
msnbc and then she criticized hillary
clinton and they called her up the
office and was like you have to clear
anything you say about hillary clinton
with us before you say it on air i did
not know that that's absurd yeah and so
she said like did that influence my
uh coverage of hillary clinton yes it
did you know i mean she's just being
honest
and
like does that sort of thing happen when
you have
like like a true institutional layer
like apparently that stuff does go on
um so
that that's one of the things that i
think people sense it's one reason why
folks are
uh so dubious
you know um
there is i have a thesis i don't know if
it's going to come true but my my thesis
is that people don't trust institutions
anymore people trust people
and so that they're going that's reality
for at least younger generations i think
that's like completely reality already
well so this is one thing i'd love for
you to fill us in on is like what the
heck does the future hold because so the
average cable news viewer is uh between
57 and 65.
you know so i'm going to talk a little
bit about this because it's sort of fun
so people looked at that math and
thought oh snap like we have to come out
come up with a streaming service that
has a different demo audience so cnn has
invested
i'm sure tens of millions of dollars in
cnn plus
because they're trying to
go
uh over the top
and get to folks um now so the average
young person
uh right now i get the sense that tic
tocs their primary information source
maybe they watch youtube clips that end
up uh being of uh comedy central uh or
some other i would just network yeah i
would just add there for breaking news
twitter twitter is obviously the first
place where things are breaking so i i
still say twitter plays a role there so
but yeah take talk twitter
all right so so yes what does the young
person's
news landscape look like or even their
time their media consumption world
yeah so i mean
your media consumption at it's been like
this for decades really forms your world
view but in regards to how much time we
are spending on screens
i think all of us are spending more time
on screens than we are outside so your
reality is at the whims of these
algorithms that
you're involved in all day tick tock is
specifically super immersive and very
curated to your interest whether
it's very much your subconscious mind
whether it's good or bad it's whatever
you're giving watch time to so um you
might think oh i don't like this content
but the reason it keeps popping up is
because you give it watch time even if
it's you're hating on it um you're still
watching yeah you're hate watching
you're still a fan in some ways in
regards to that so
very much getting um information you
hear that people are watching me on tick
tock
you must have watched something
that made you want to see it anyway oh
yeah and um very dedicated haters are
basically equivalent to fans at the end
of the day that's what this algorithm um
really pushes but
um so tick tock um i'm sure all your
fans love you jules i
i don't know i don't know like um i
think we can get to more convo about
that but so yeah tick tock but the
information is very pushed to you
instagram of course is based on who you
follow and something that's big on
instagram um amongst youth are these
like infographic instagram accounts
which you've probably seen it's kind of
like the carousel post of breaking down
information about something they're
often run honestly by like
people in their 20s even high schoolers
so a lot of the information can be a
little more uh emotional driven in a lot
of situations and then twitter is where
you're going for breaking news like if
any platform is down if instagram's down
if tick tock's down you run to twitter
and you just search obviously instagram
down the thing about twitter that's um
nice um and that's harder on
instagram it's like almost impossible
tic toc it's harder is the search
function on twitter obviously because
all the content is all
words you're able to search anything and
find something in regards to it
um but what gets scary about all of this
is that
reality kind of feels like it's often
subjective in a lot of ways even on
google you're able to something as
simple as um is the color blue happy or
sad if you type in i've done this before
i'm like is the color blue represent
happiness something comes up
does the color blue represent sadness
something comes up you do the straight
line approach and it usually comes up
with like sadness instead but how you
are searching information because
google's still a big huge part of
everyone's lives aside from these three
social media pla
those three main social media platforms
for news
still google's still a huge part of your
life and how you go about a google
search has so much to do with what it is
so blue is said right what lewis said
yeah blue is said to me but you can
literally type in
is blue associated with happiness and
something comes up first thing like an
article that does state that so you can
do that with any that's a very trivial
example but with any type of information
how you search is how it's going to come
back to you
um
[Laughter]
very much baby
very much maybe so
um
yeah those three platforms tick tock
twitter instagram are the main ways
people or young people are curing their
information and then google kind of for
supporting evidence but that supporting
evidence and how you search
can really be yeah subjective in how you
the information returns to you and again
it's for how these kids form their
worldview today
[Music]
does what can you project forward based
upon what you think that a lot of young
people are seeing um so i ran for
president which you remember well um and
it turns out that the vast majority of
voters resemble cable news viewers in
terms of their agent demo and that's
obviously going to change um you know a
political consultant said to me like hey
no one knows what the heck's going to
happen in 10 years when these folks age
out
and the folks you're talking about
become kind of prime
voting age or not less so i mean prime
voting age is still a bit older than gen
z is going to be in 10 years um but what
what what does your crystal ball say uh
in terms of
the young people
and the world view you're talking about
so i think we're going we've been going
through a ton of trial and error over
the past few years it's just obviously
we've been on social media for
like i said since i was
nine probably the platforms actually
like 12 13 when i first got on facebook
for example
but over the past three years it's
become so much more immersive much in
part due to the pandemic and how much
time we're spending on it and we've gone
through so much trial and error and yeah
what cancel culture which i think
everyone can agree now is just like not
even a thing more so for people at the
very top of like the influencer and
content creator realm if they get
canceled they end up getting like more
followers and more traction because to
the point of algorithms you're then
interested in how they're reacting to
all of these things and you're paying
more attention to them and if they don't
pay any mind to it then you're more
invested in that so castle culture is
not a thing anymore as you're saying i
think it is when in regards to kind of
mid-range following and smaller like you
can really just like put someone off the
map which is
terrible but also i've noticed when this
has happened to even the mid-range or
smaller creators they'll come back a few
months later and people are like
interested in like how they've evolved
they might take a break from social
media then people are so interested in
them when they come back because at the
end of the day everyone knows
we have all made personal mistakes like
we're all human so when these people
come back subconsciously you're thinking
about that and you're interested in what
they have to offer now after like
they've evolved over time maybe they
went off the platform and it ends up
like most people i've seen this happen
to come back and they are in the same
spot that they were in before if not
greater so i think we're going through a
lot of trial and error in regards to
that
and because of that um i think
people over the next three years
hopefully sooner are just going to flock
to those who
of course think critically do their
diligence in terms of research but also
aren't afraid to uplift
uplift the rights of people they
typically oppose and also
uplift the wrongs of people that they
typically agree with at the end of the
day that's what we're seeing people
flock to in terms of individuals and
that's what we're going to need because
like i was saying a lot of the times we
feel like reality is subjective because
of how much information there is on
social media it's been compounding
content over the past few years you can
find something to validate any point
and it's going to be super important to
like yeah
flock to those individuals it's harder
when it becomes these big media sources
because there's
all these politics involved also like
even in projects you know like um
sometimes it's easier to do things on
your own because when you have a lot of
people involved it's like and you're
having too many critiques and everything
at the end
it affects the end product so people are
flocking to individuals because they
feel like um there's more organic and
authentic approaches that's one reason
why people come to you but continue
and then um so i think too it's just
going to be interesting as we see yeah
gen z get into leadership in regards to
the digital footprint conversation we
were having earlier yeah people are just
going to people do that now with older
content but it's going to be such
immersive and personal content that we
have on
these candidates from when they were
young
it's going to be really interesting but
i think people are going to have more
empathy in regards to it because we've
all grown up so immersed in digital that
way of course i think older news
correspondents
are going to take single videos maybe
out of context and in reality a tick
tock feed and instagram feed
it tells a story of someone's life and
it's kind of um
not that great to take out single short
form post because they're often out of
context with a bigger story i think
people are going to have more empathy
towards it but it's going to be
interesting to see how that all plays
out well that's a relatively positive
projection hopefully certainly it's it's
going to be a bit of a rocky road there
but if people are searching for
rationality uh and becoming more
empathetic and forgiving of foibles uh
online i mean that's a world i can
endorse yeah i think every everyone's
exhausted of the current nature like
you feel like you're walking on
eggshells all the time you feel
restraint and maybe
being yourself in certain ways because
yeah all these attackers and you know
everyone at the end of the day knows and
i see this in my comment section because
i uplift these types of conversations a
lot the people who are often in
tick-tock comment sections or whatever
it is um
trolling
hating whatever are people without a
profile picture who don't have their
name tied to their username and that's
also an interesting conversation like in
the future are we gonna see i think it
was australia that
proposed that like your driver's license
regardless if you have like a
pseudonym username or like you're kind
of anonymous online
does your should your driver's license
have to be tied to every account so
there is that accountability in regards
to these this type of content that
you're pushing whether it's just hateful
comments or whatever there should
probably be some accountability um
i think we're going to see a lot more of
how that evolves other the day people i
i'm seeing more people have disdain
towards those who
act online that way um so i honestly
have a more positive outlook i think it
just gets scary when it comes to yeah
how how to decipher real what's real and
what's fake
well i think you're attracting the right
sort of person jules because the kind of
work that you do um we we have a
fascinating media landscape ahead and i
know you're going to be
a big part of both forming it and also
helping people understand it so thank
you
so much for helping shine light on some
of these topics that i know a lot of
people are extraordinarily
uh curious about and interested in
because they really will shape our
future i completely agree and yeah thank
you for having me jules turpak everyone
follow her on
tick tock instagram twitter
uh she's a voice of reason for the next
generation uh and super grateful to you
for being here thank you andrew it's
great hey jules
[Music]
you